foreign
okay let's see all right hello everyone
um we are doing a meeting about error
handling
and there's a lot of complicated stuff
on the screen which I don't understand
so maybe somebody can explain what it is
right well so I mean what we're
I mean there are a couple things we're
probably aiming to talk about today
um the first one is that we've reached a
stage in in this project where we have
and we've got a lot of uh design work we
have a big design document and um you
know that's been going on the last few
months but what we have now is an actual
prototype implementation of some of
those ideas
um and we're also probably going to talk
a bit about how we want to integrate you
know this work you know what we're
imagining will be kind of the new wave
error handling with our existing ways of
doing error handling um this is language
level error handling this is not the UI
I've ever handling is that correct
correct this is functions and yeah
operations and semantics
okay and and just to be clear the I mean
my way of thinking about this continues
to be you know you write a piece of code
and you mostly think about the primary
code path that isn't the error path
and then you say oh but I need to
bulletproof this code what can I add to
bulletproof this code is that the
workflow that you are pursuing or is not
that not the workflow you're pursuing so
the the general point of what we're at
is is where you I mean somebody who is
intentionally like it's code that that
is doing some lower level operations
going to be issuing its own errors about
what happened so we have functions that
you know create errors and functions
that handle errors or the the users can
use to create errors and handle errors
um
no I mean I think it is probably solving
that problem because the whole point is
that I mean
right the the one of the main things
sorry but I don't think what
go ahead well one of the main things
that we're going to be talking about is
about the sort of hierarchy of errors
and so on which is directly relevant to
that because I think that a lot of the
way that you sort of bulletproof things
is well first when you write something
you know it's sort of uh
you know it depends on how you know that
you need a way of specifying what kinds
of areas you care about and so on and
what places in the hierarchy you
actually want to handle versus ignore
and that's that's one of the things
okay but I mean is it something that you
expect that you have to put into the
code right when you first write the code
or is it something that can be
realistically put in as an add-on
I think Parts could be added on I mean I
think that there's there's like there's
two different parts
your audio keeps on mushing out
just FYI
okay I can check my mic but um no I mean
I was just saying though I mean I think
there's there's the the there's sort of
two parts there's sort of the consumer
side and there's the producer side right
I mean there's the question of I wrote
this big long function and uh you know
I'm only thinking about the primary code
path versus I'm using this this function
and I'm not thinking about
well
right I mean basically there's the
question of of
what if there's a function from some
package what types of Errors from that
function do I care about and do I want
to catch versus the matter of I wrote
some big long piece of code and I need
to sort of instrument it to add these
different error case if that makes sense
yep
all right so let's dive in let's look at
this line here I do I mean I agree with
everything Christopher said but I do
want to say that the the context for
this discussion this is kind of bored
out of you know a desire to unify kind
of the different conventions that have
sprung up in Wolfram internal projects
for doing area handling that that kind
of rhyme with each other but we don't
have a standard set of tools to do so it
comes from that that kind of large-scale
software engineering background
um okay more so than an individual in a
notebook piece of programming where
you're just trying to handle more errors
so I mean do we imagine that the thing
you have let's look at function
repository stuff which is fairly small
scale code mostly
do we imagine that somebody could go in
and say oh I'm going to take this
functional repository functions and I'm
going to add some error handling with
these kinds of tools to functional
pository entries is that realistic or is
that not what this is going for
or the larger functions I mean I know
physics project has a lot of functions
that are made up of sub functions that
probably could be reasonable for really
tiny kind of utility functions that are
composition of you know a few other
functions it probably wouldn't make
sense let's Dive In
yeah
um so
I mean I think what I'm going to walk
through first and you can interrupt you
know with questions and everything
um as we go along but this is kind of
showing concretely what we've had before
in a design notebook but not implemented
and just showing how how it actually
works and I should stress this is the
product of a couple of working meetings
to to flesh out this implementation it's
by no means finished or polished you
know and even names are a bit in flux so
uh roughly how many functions are there
that we're how many how many different
functions are there oh probably half a
dozen right now I mean six like
something like that okay
um just getting a scope yep okay cool
that's fine yeah so the first function
again you know like I said you know in a
larger project you want to develop a
hierarchy of Errors the first thing you
have to do is kind of declare that there
is an error of a particular type and
then errors when we say errors we mean
specifically failure objects that have a
tag of a specific type so right now I
mean in the language we have you know we
have failure objects
if it's about failure objects create
failure uh perhaps it should be yeah
okay um uh but failure you know right
now we have conventions that failures
take string tags what we're proposing is
that they take symbols as tags as well
but additionally that they can take
lists of symbols
um you know really one kind of Muddy up
the symbol table with this
well okay so that's a detailed thing
okay
absolutely yes I mean I think it's like
that there's there's a lot of like
there's a lot of value in being able to
have for example a documented a
documented symbol where it's like this
represents this kind of error and here's
its position the hierarchy I see I'm
surprised
as opposed to a head of a of a thing
where there's an error type that has you
know a foo with a bunch of innodes in it
right I mean you could imagine you could
imagine instead of having a unified
failure object we have a different
symbol for every one of these different
cases and you have some way of testing
is this you know I don't know not a
failure object but is this a failure
thing right or might have any head but I
think that's much weirder or more
complicated yeah but we we don't really
need to have symbols there I mean we
have a lot of Precedence for documenting
strings like import types okay never
mind
there's something there yeah the primary
place that tag the reason we want that
to be assembled is the first argument
there are others have come up is in
packages a symbol is automatically
unique you don't have to worry about
namespacing it because its context is
unique to your package I see
that would also be true if who was the
head there rather than just a naked
symbol
true yeah I mean I think it's going to
happen
well I think I think I think you should
be a bit more patient because there's a
reason why they want to watch the symbol
okay terrific yeah okay
so okay so basic and this is you know
stateful thing you register an error
type and ignore these info outputs
um you know here I'm registering an
error type that doesn't have any other
Associated like um either the hierarchy
of error types it doesn't have anything
associated with it so there's an empty
list here uh but if it did you would
list them here
um there's this expand tag function this
is not a function users are going to
call this is part of the implementation
but what it does is it does essentially
kind of rule replacement on whatever tag
you've you know is passed as an argument
to expand it out into the full set of
tags that are that are declared by that
uh well by that tag so if Foo was
declared with um well maybe I could just
show this I haven't understood these
subtanks but I don't think I need to yet
why don't you keep going then we'll come
back all right sure so now that we've
registered this error type we can pass
it to raise raise is just it's basically
just throw with a with a custom error
tag with and you know with argument
validation that what it's throwing is a
failure you know so throw is kind of
like generic control flow raise is you
know error specific exception control
flow
um so that's how you kind of throw one
of these failures uh handle is a
function that that is what you use to
Cache these oh hold on my Blaze actually
disrupts the control flow it's like
throw it disrupts control flow at that
point it disrupts control flow and it
does so unconditionally there's no such
thing as kind of like a quieted failure
if a raise appears in code that means
it's going to do control flow okay
um it'll Branch
um so handle is how you catch these
things and by default and it's one
argument form it just handles everything
that's been thrown
um but we're not you know this is this
is kind of the the quick and dirty way
we're imagining that people ought to be
specifying rules to handle the errors
they specifically know and care about
um
so I'm just going to register another
error type
this is handle raising of something but
handling only the bar error type so we
can see that it lets through this Foo
error because well it didn't why do you
have to put that second argument to
raise of the null Association
so this would otherwise just say handle
of rays of Foo comma bar and then it
will the Rays the foo will escape that
handle because it was only handling bars
right
okay but by the way that Association
there because you can put data there oh
I realize that but I'm just saying that
the default case of the minimum wage
doesn't work because the argument order
here is a little bit funky right because
the the um well I see the point is that
raise effectively has no payload
because unlike throw which has a payload
that it throws
to catch
raise has no payload
well the payload is constructed so it
constructs a failure object that is then
thrown right but but throw you can throw
a ball you know and there's an actual
ball to be caught whereas raise is just
like oh I'm raising a flag I'm I've
there's no but there's no nobody gets
the flag so to speak it's just well in a
raise raise does throw a ball just the
ball the ball is always a failure object
and it can you know if it just knows the
tag it can construct a simple thing no I
get it so but the main point is that
throw needs a payload as its first
argument which is the thing you're
throwing whereas raise does not because
it does need attacks well
I think I think let's let's tease this
out because like I think what's maybe
Stephen what you're trying to say and
tell me if I'm wrong is like raise as an
implementation detail constructs a
failure object that it throws but you
can imagine a different implementation
where no failure is constructed if it's
not actually handled anywhere and the
object isn't needed
um look I'm sorry I would say I would
say raise is is it's more like raising a
semaphort than raising a flag right
because there might there might be
nothing written on it but there could be
some very complicated sequence of stuff
with useful information in it I I get it
but the thing is okay
throw raise is a is a one-trick throw so
to speak in the sense that throw you can
throw the actual data that you wanted to
get whereas raise you can only throw
there is an error condition here
yes okay fine you can include you have
to include the metadata at a sub level
it's not yeah
right so if you if you're communicating
I mean I'm just trying to understand how
we explain things to people so throw is
you are disrupting the control flow but
you are delivering some actual data that
you're throwing to the catch
whereas here you're see the thing that
bothers me okay I gotta say the term
raise and I'm I admit that I'm getting
into naming the thing raised just as
like oh yeah we'll we'll fly this flag
that's nice and we'll keep going right
it doesn't make it
as clear I mean throw is much more of an
action I don't know it's somehow
but in other languages I think people
use the term raise and exception which
is a kind of a catastrophic situation
yeah I know and the problem with throw
is that we have these one and two
argument forms and it I mean it's just a
very awkward thing to use I think the
and keeping the thing that is passed up
to be structured for this kind of error
handling I think is no no right thing
it's the right thing I'm just saying in
terms of distinguishing the throw
functionality from the raised
functionality I understand the
distinction I'm a little bit unconvinced
about the name rays but let's keep going
we can revisit it yeah okay um all right
um one thing about the Android rules
like the second argument to see that
you're doing a replacement and and you
return a function
so we're gonna we can talk about that
We spelled out a lot of different
possible designs for what this could
look like
um like what you know it's a rule
delayed is this you know a thing that is
applied is it a function object what is
it
this is what we settled on and we can
discuss the trade-offs if we want to get
into that but um it was not chosen
arbitrarily
um
I don't think I've never seen in the in
the language something where you do a
replacement and you're doing a function
oh yeah
I don't wear
I mean I don't know if you if you say
nearest functions and options to nearest
or something
why is that yeah I mean that's a very
traditional
yeah it's just an option you know
nearest function arrow and then there's
a a function
well except that this is a replacement
it's not an option
so the other here before we get into
that let me mention this is not strictly
a pattern like you can't put an
arbitrary pattern in here this has to be
a list of tags or a single tag okay
that's just that's weird because then
that's sort of hijacking the colon
greater than
you know say well okay again let's get
the bigger picture before we go into
um okay so let me just understand what
this is doing so this as a side effect
is executing that function on what
does it means
yeah that's what's printed okay but but
this thing
is saying your handling
any error that has the tag Foo
and that's it's kind of
um
it's like it contains any sort of thing
so if this was like Foo or bar this
would handle any exception that has the
tag Foo or the tag bar I mean imagine
I mean you're saying that out loud yeah
I'm not sure that's right this is not
this is a finer point that has not been
worked through okay okay I mean that it
seems to me using the pattern language
makes sense here but I've got a
different question in the ancient event
handler function how does it deal with
the different can we look at the
documentation for event handler
because it has a way
um yeah so
it
it's very much like what we uh were just
talking about except that it's using
um expression evaluation rather than
function application
but it's very similar idea
yeah with the expression evaluation only
makes sense because of crazy Dynamic
stuff
yeah
okay so let's keep going
right
um so that's handling so this is where
we get into advice so uh I think I want
to like there's kind of I've been
thinking this in my head of like the you
know if there's like an iceberg there's
like the above the water line and the
below the water line and they have
different rules so errors are things
that unconditionally trigger control
flow if you have a raise that always
causes control flow and you know the
reader of the code can rely on that
advice is something more more analogous
to messages where if you have like you
know it's it's outside it's code outside
of the thing issuing the advice that
decides whether to do control flow you
know it's you know it's like check
excuse me I'm I'm you know as you're
saying this the word exception will be a
better word than raise because raise it
just sounds so passive it's like
nothing's gonna happen here
and raise is the term in many languages
used I know but they say race is an
exception yes yes I know raises an
exception but do they use the term raise
or do they say do they use the the key
word raise
yes yes I think no wait a python is yeah
race
yes
well okay
yeah
I don't know I I don't like it it seems
too it's throwing note in JavaScript I
guess
uh what's Russ doing
West doesn't have to have exceptions
like that like that yeah anyway the
point should be I mean you can call it
accept but no
we already have an acceptance pattern
matching yeah but again
stop confusing it with throw it's you
know we've got to be able to document
throw throws an expression that you want
to whose value you want to use
you know raise
you know generates sort of
disrupts control distinction
all right okay I mean because Ray is the
thing currently called raise throws a
failure object effectively that that you
want to then you know I know and that
then you might decide what to do next so
you're consuming it right but you're
deciding what to do next as opposed to
that is my prize you know I went down
into the salt mines and I found this
amazing Ruby or something and I throw it
back up and that's my result well no it
might be the prize because you know if
you if you're riding some package and
you have some function and you know oh
it failed the the the prize result is
that failure object okay but in fact
that's a large fraction of the uses uses
of throw right now
maybe but not the only uses I use throw
when I'm doing a search and I finally
find something and I throw the result
sure sure
the real reason why we shouldn't use you
know the word throw anywhere near here
is because I think the the ways of of
managing them is totally different like
for example you don't use catch to catch
these things
um by the way the term fail is
interesting which you just wrote down
anyway let's keep going let's not get
hung up on this name
let's talk about it
yeah so advice and this is another thing
where the name is
placeholder but advice is analogous to
messages they can trigger control flow
but they don't have to and probably
typically won't trigger control flow
um so similarly to a lot of the things
in the structure of advice is similar to
what we're imagining uh is the structure
of failures so they have tags as well
um so I guess here we don't actually
have a registration mechanism
um but you you would register some kind
of listener this is just a function uh
and
is a noun like failure
it's a it's a yeah advice is a noun
advice so if you have you have an advice
object or something
um
this name is
right yeah we talked about this recently
because the you know yeah right this
name is very uh unclear if nothing else
because
the thing for throwing an advice you
know the function for throwing advice
one of the things we considered was
advised but that's impossible to have
advice and advice
okay okay well all right but anyway so
this is
gosh
it's an interesting concept okay so this
this is a symbolic advice construct
okay yeah but
and and the analogy for this though is
these are these are kind of like
glorified messages
yeah I mean and the main advantage I
mean the main advantages are both that
the ways of sort of catching and
managing them will hopefully be simpler
than the messages or you know better
than messages but but also that you can
include real data in them because right
now with messages you know it's just a
string that gets printed you can't
include
advisory
but can I suggest it's like this this
system is actually very interesting but
um it's like a signal right I mean there
are other you you are basically emitting
a signal and then another guy is is
registering and handling for the signal
and you can do it with something more
than just messages with it
it's it's yeah you're sending an event
and then another guy is listening to the
event right
yeah yeah it's more General than
messages it could be used potentially
for a bunch of other things as well so
basically you have to think about it as
certain propagation of some information
occurring early in the stack in the
execution stack up or to the upper
colors of that function
I mean in in general this is a very
interesting concept that I think we we
we we should try to we could propagate
it a little I mean imagine like you know
you you want to connect something that
is doing something when you do Cloud
deployed when you do import or export or
other stuff like that so in general
function could have their own handlers
and say you know
um before I'm running this I'm going to
send this signal out so that you can
register and do stuff
well this is a better version of the
thing that I've been pushing for years
which is messages that are off by
default
you're saying that an import could send
out some advisories that say oh by the
way this this file has this or that
properties you may not care about that
you may not want to actually pay
attention to that piece of advice or you
may want to but you know well generally
you could connect something that is
doing something else every time we run
an export right
uh so so you're going to intercept every
export call and do something else like
whatever uh well we haven't thought
about it in a a great depth but one
thing we were thinking about was to
actually restrict the non-locality of
which functions in which order can
intercept things we wanted this to be as
unobtrusive in terms of diverting the
standard control flow as possible in in
contrast in contrast to errors
yeah okay I mean one of the one of the
things we want to keep in mind is that
what we're talking about here is the low
level substrate for building robust
programs so if there's too much
complexity and unpredictability in that
substrate
that kind of is a permanent shaky
foundation so we want to be clear you
know we don't want to have something
that is as general as general as excuse
me as general as we could possibly
imagine it to be
um because that makes it harder
basically what's happening is you're
putting bottles out in the ocean with
these advice objects and
the the the sender doesn't necessarily
you want it to be the case that the
sender has no idea where it's going to
land
yeah whereas in the case of raise the
sender is just giving up and saying I'm
out of you know get out of here
yeah and still in this analogy the
sender in it in the case of race they'll
just shoot something straight to the sky
well here they just put this bottle and
whoever picks that up does was that
whatever they want yes
but okay I mean I think they're both
interesting mechanisms so okay keep
going okay so well we're near the end um
but just these are some examples of
we're trying to come up with concrete
motivation for these so this is an
example showing you might have a service
that you know handling login events and
you may not care about that but you may
want to kind of as they happen do
something like log them to an output and
include actual useful information in
them
um so this is just an example of that
um another thing is we've talked for a
long time you know we have these
messages for array unpacking but they
are not actually as I understand that
some people have complained that they're
not super useful for tracking down where
the unpacking happened so we could
imagine a more robust unpacking event
type thing that actually says what is
the content of the array that was
unpacked and maybe on optional operation
field that could say well hey this array
was unpacked while doing an append II
operation yeah the basic point is that a
message
I mean our convention for messages let's
let's review messages
invented you know 36 years ago or
something now okay a message has slots
that are really only intended for human
consumption that is if you look at the
text of a message if you bring up a
message I mean let's say um uh General
colon colon count
oxyt
ARG CT
okay that's a typical message
right now
this
message effectively I mean
the alternative thing to do here would
be or and would have been or would still
be
that
you know that thing can be applied as a
string template right right now if you
take that object you say string template
of that object
just get that string template okay now
now apply that
I'll apply that string template to uh I
think you apply it to a list or is it
verox
list
so like if you apply like that it's
about okay all right so say a comma B
there
okay all right fine so this is a
positional
this is positional now what you're
suggesting is
that
um
uh
your general your more General thing
your more general advice object
routinely takes an association whereas
messages right now are expecting
essentially uh you know positional
arguments am I making sense
mm-hmm
also Stephen message by itself is a side
effect while what we are doing here by
itself does not produce any side effect
per se
no I understand message actually by
default
I mean in okay this is why I keep on
emphasizing messages that are off by
default
okay
I mean in the end we will have to make a
bridge between this mechanism that
you're proposing and the messages
mechanism possibly subsuming the
messages mechanism inside the advisory
mechanism
foreign
why do you claim that this advice
messaging advice mechanism can help with
unpacking I mean right the problem is
the problem with unpacking is that right
it's done in the evaluator it doesn't
actually happen during any particular
evaluation so I don't see how this is
helping me no I don't understand the
point here is what is generated the
issue is the unpacking messages are off
by default yep and point one and the
question is then how do you discover and
make use of messages that are off by
default and the answer is right now you
just very ham-fistedly switch them on
okay and then they display but even
making use of it if you wanted to
programmatically make use of them that's
not easy to do problem number one
problem number two the material that is
provided to the messages well we could
probably look up the packing message
what does it have what is the what is
the data for the packing messages is it
General unpack or something what is it
called
yeah I don't uh Utah do you know I've
never actually used them uh I don't know
the tag off the top of my head right you
do on-off packing and then uh
sorry all enough
dollar message groups oh packing
oh is there a group for oh yeah yeah
generally okay that's okay so let's say
just look at what general unpack has on
it
why didn't you just map over like a
range with some uncompatable function or
something like that
well fine but this is showing us the
junior version of what will be the
unpacking advisory
but the unpacking advisory would have an
association with more stuff this just
has one positional argument
right right
because presumably that's all the
information that's available right I
mean there you can see that there are
like five different messages there yeah
depending on exactly where that's an
implementation feature of of the fact
that right well right but wait wait wait
wait uh Connor made the claim that you
people complain about the lack of
information and we could use this to
provide more information
my claim is there will be exactly the
same amount of information yes right
that's right that's right this would be
a place were we to put Hooks and the
code to deliver more information in this
case we actually have a way to deliver
more information as opposed to messages
where all we can do is produce some
positional arguments no there's exactly
the same amount of information hold on I
think I I think this is not the point
right I mean I was this I included this
as an example maybe it's a bad example
right I mean but
the internal code produces some amount
of telemetry and you can package that
Telemetry in an advisory object or in a
message but it's still producing the
same amount of telemetry correct it I
sure okay now uh still one thing I
wanted to add is that there are other
things we might want to include like a
stacked race which could be a useful
thing for this new system that's fine
can I make a point the word Telemetry I
kind of think is an interesting
term maybe too weird but I just think
that's an interesting term for those
advisory things because that's really
what what it is isn't it I mean
Telemetry is not something where you you
don't expect the spacecraft to
immediately you know fire its thrusters
as a result of sending out a piece of
telemetry
although although I would argue
telemetry
Telemetry makes it sound more like
logging yeah I agree I agree I think
I think Telemetry also has a slightly
negative connotation unfortunately wow
in some circles well I mean I'm not
saying everyone feels this way but
people kind of it's the word when people
complain about an app that has been
sharing too much information about them
all right anyway just a conceptual thing
okay all right so let's go back up then
so
what is the relationship Okay so we've
we've got
I'm still confused about something okay
so
at the beginning could you go scroll up
to the top
so we've got these
razors
which are raises according to a tag
you don't get to raise unless you can
specify a tag there is no generic rays
correct
well no you shouldn't say at the moment
because well you don't want that you
don't want it I mean that as soon as we
have a generic raise we've basically
just re-implemented throw
so let me I mean so I agree conceptually
but the problem is and this may not be a
problem right but I think it's worth
recognizing that there's a the slight ux
challenge here of having to register an
error type
it's it's fine but it's a little onerous
especially if you're trying to quickly
work through code where maybe you want
to include error handling you don't even
know what all of your final error types
are going to be
um there's kind of a you know like this
happens to me you know I'm working
through a project I want to add error
handling to it but you know all I really
know about the error at the moment is
like something went wrong and I want to
just raise something that has like a
string message and some arguments you
know and that's okay
let's talk about let's talk about what
this looks like to the programmer okay
so you did something and maybe even when
you're initially writing the code you
know there is a this
was an error case but you have not yet
defined a taxonomy of errors
yeah therefore you have not yet given
you know invented your tags
yeah right
I mean we could have some top level tag
that is always present right if we
really wanted all right yeah we have
actually at the top of the hierarchy
internally we have a general error
that's going to be the parent tag of
them all
what's this with parent tags I don't
understand the stuff yeah so this
Stephen this has been the part that we
haven't discussed yet basically tags can
be inherited so uh this allows us to
build the taxonomies or the hierarchies
of Errors because certain errors can be
more General and include sub errors or
there are specific cases okay so hold on
a second again let's zoom out for a
second because we we have to remember
the thing I keep on emphasizing you know
this is essentially automatic
programming not in the same sense that
people meant automatic programming in 19
in the 1950s
um well they meant it was doing Fortran
rather than machine code
um but uh
it's automatic programming as in you're
trying to effectively get functionality
written without explicitly writing it
because you're trying to like bucket
different you know uh code pods Etc et
cetera Etc so I want to ask this
question the hierarchy the notion of
hierarchical errors
is that in fact a natural notion in all
cases
in so far as we're automating
programming I mean this was one of the
things you know this was the
object-oriented programming idea in a
sense was this kind of hierarchy
maybe I don't know I mean is it is it
the right idea I think that's what you
want to do it okay oh and I think the
others share that view as well think
about them as more as scoping because
can you imagine programming without B
without scoping I guess okay so scoping
is hierarchical so you're saying and
that has worked well to have
I mean that was the thing where people
when first people were trying to you
know do code well invent lambdas and
then do code with Landers people didn't
know
I mean there is wackiness and scoping
like you've got an x on the outside and
is it the same X as the X on the inside
and so on
but okay so your argument is scoping is
tree like and hierarchical
and yeah and this this hierarchy here in
some sense can be considered an analog
of scope in the world of errors in some
sense and the scoping here means that
basically you only want to catch certain
classes of errors but not but not others
yeah now I do that I mean is it a good
idea to to to think it about in terms of
inheritance rather than traits
oh I think I think we could think about
this as like message groups right you
know message groups give you a bunch of
right you only turn on or off one thing
that controls a bunch of specific cases
and here you could you know Define right
our count errors right and then
you know I'm just not clear that
containment is the right thing because
like there's an error okay let's say
numerical roundoff errors of various
kinds okay
there's one that's a round off error
there's one that's a convergence error
there's one that say something else
error why aren't those intersecting
groups of errors
why do you think that there's a
hierarchy to groups of Errors right I
mean this is why I was saying that
probably we should think it about in
terms of Trades rather than than
inheritance because let's say that you
want to combine together to to things
that I'm sure you should do it but let's
say for the sake of the argument that
you want to do it like at zero division
error and uh file not found error if you
do it in terms of inheritance probably
normally it's going to be a mess right
because they expect different things so
you you need something clear that says
you know that there are zero division
error got this kind of payload and the
final found get these other payload and
um and you can combine them together
sorry
okay I'm just gonna say two maybe two
quick clarifications I mean one one
thing is that of course you could yeah I
I you could catch or handle multipliers
at once so you could handle you know
errors from division by zero and final
outfounded the same thing the other
thing is that I mean for the the
structure of the hierarchy I I think we
talked about it being a dag not a tree
so some of the issues it's really
multiple inheritance it's yeah yeah
multiple inheritance and I think and I
think that we have to think mostly about
inheritance as about a way to form
groups of uh groups of errors that we
want to catch I'm confused because once
you if you've clustered together two
errors but yet their Association keys
are different how can you have a
function that applies to both of them
while this will bring us more towards
the internals of what we do there but uh
we planned that there will be certain
validators that the author of given
package or whoever creates certain types
of Errors they would know what form of
error they want uh to be produced and so
they will Define validators that will
basically tell whether this error is
actually well formed or not
no but the point that I'm making is
the thing is pretty confusing is right
now
for a message
it is just positional you feed it you
know I'm sure we could generate a an
error upon an error by feeding a message
a collection of arguments that it wasn't
expecting
okay so similarly here the question is
it's got certain keys that it
is going to generate
um
right so I I think the idea is that
suppose you had some category of like I
don't know numerical error or something
like that which includes you know
convergence and who knows why you know I
I don't know what it is but suppose you
have something like that the idea is
that you would specify sort of a
validator for testing whether a
numerical error that you gave is really
a well-formed numerical error and you'd
expect that would be something like
checking that it has certain keys in its
Association
and so then the idea is that when you
declare that uh you know when you
declare that oh I have a particular
thing I have a convergence there and
this inherits from or this is a child of
the numerical error then you know that's
something that you have to specify when
you create that that sub-error type and
so you're sort of responsible for
knowing that well okay so the now the
this sub error type
like it has to you know in order for an
error to pass it has to pass the
validator for the sub air and the super
error
yeah and again the point there is you
asked about clashing I think the point
is that
you are taking responsibility for having
checked that these error fields are
distinct if you're going to declare that
they have an inheritance relationship
you can't you know you have to have this
explicit create error type to create one
of these things that that has multiple
tags in the same failure object you
can't there's no mechanism where that
kind of handle happens automatically for
errors that weren't declared to be
compatible by someone
um
all right so I do let's just understand
the way you write this code so
you raise something
with a tag
I don't understand why the tag and the
association are separated but anyway
okay this is a shorthand for
you
could
write this if you wanted to
um but it's just this does work like
we're planning to implement that but
it's you know people are gonna have a
lot of these so we want to make it as
short as possible
I think that's a separate level of the
issue but okay all right so then
okay
so now you're going to handle this
and the first point about handle is it
stops the sort of throwing of control
flow
you know it's propagated out to the
point where it hits the handle
and then the handle evaluates much like
enclose confirm
the handle then
does whatever the Handler says in its
side effect argument it's supposed to do
and then what does the handle return
what does handle return
I think it would probably return the
result of these right hand sides and
easily just to replace over the the
catch that you're doing
basically yeah yeah wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait so I
mean it's not right unlike a throw for
example where
you know let's say you're doing a search
and you say I found something here it is
you throw it you the result of the
search is the thing you found
okay and then you keep going with the
code
in this case
it's almost like this is just an element
of a compound expression that has no
that has nothing going on other than
producing a side effect which is pretty
weird I don't understand how how handle
will get used in code no it's still it's
it's different here basically the first
Handler that matches the tag
uh is applied and it's not necessarily a
side effect the right hand side of this
Handler is what the result will be
yeah okay I understand so
so what the heck is this like
I mean there is a style of coding in
which you just give a result and you say
slash Dot
blah blah blah that's kind of what this
is doing
this is this is like a switch
basically yeah yes it's a switch that
that catches as well like it catches and
switches
which also falls through for any
exception that has the tag not matching
by any of the handlers they will just
flow through but what do you mean by
fall through it means the failure is
still flying yes yes exactly
yeah
for it the failure goes through and I
want to stress I mean you know this may
be there's not may not be a direct
analog for this move from language but
this is essentially equivalent to catch
in many programming languages our our
catch is actually unusual in that it
doesn't allow
kind of specification of the kinds of
things you want to catch like we use
tags but tags are kind of out of band
mechanism
um in many languages you know yeah how
how does this relate to enclose confirm
and close confirm has to propagate
things rather locally from one layer to
another
for exceptions you can sort of Pierce
through a whole stack of intermediate
function calls
so instead of in close
I mean couldn't confirm keep flying
until
this is the thing where you're sending
the the um
you know your
your exceptioning
and it keeps flying until you finally
get to a net that catches you
correct
correct yes
doesn't enclose have a mechanism do that
as well but it's not its default case
it's default well it's tags
you can use text and then close much
like you can and right I understand but
the default is the lexical confirming
closure is the most useful case
customer is that right yes yeah when
that when you start using tags it's
already becoming very another version of
what we're proposing here
well but we can't have seven versions of
it so
right I think I think probably the
well
is still broken Christopher you're still
there's some packet loss anyway never
mind I'm just complaining go ahead
well I was gonna say I think the main
the main value in the in this newer
stuff is first of all the the
categorization and hierarchy of of
errors and then you know sort of better
sort of automated creation and handling
of failure objects
and then and then some more non-local
propagation stuff but yeah right but so
there's also maybe something to to keep
in mind that these examples where the
Handler just print something and so on
is are not what I would expect to be
typical typically say we have code that
reads my file and eventually that file
is over and there will be an error
raised end of file error and then the
Handler would not Point anything because
it just Returns the result so it
completely gobbles up the arrow and days
and the arrow the enter file Arrow isn't
isn't really an error so you would
normally see handles to just return
results and be silent about what
happened for for these kinds of messages
that are not right it's like out of I
mean in a sense the thing you just
described
well let's see the one version of that
code would be that there's a symbolic
representation of end of file which we
have
and that you have an if statement
basically wrapped around the place we
read from the file that says if it's the
end of file
thing then raise that error yes well no
but but what you're saying here is that
the style of programming you're
proposing
is
that it's kind of
you're just going merrily along you're
doing whatever you're doing reading
things from the file
and maybe building up some intermediate
data structure and then on end of file
yeah that's the first thing the first
okay those are two alternate cases yeah
I mean the kind of thing we have that so
far we have always
our error handling was through return
values and if statements on it and that
is what what the original comment was
today in the meeting I mean it should be
possible to write a piece of code where
you don't even see that if statement
right you just pretend that it it goes
on forever and outside there is the
Handler which then Triggers on on that
exception that is raised right so that's
that's the point the point is it's like
messages that are off by default you're
merely running your code and you know if
something weird happens see the thing
I'm not understanding the thing here's
the thing I'm not understanding
okay and maybe this is your advisory
concept as well yeah maybe this is the
right thing
you know
sometimes you want a thing that from the
inside says I'm giving up I'm sending up
my you know Escape pod or whatever I'm
I'm done I can't you know I'm I'm
pressing the eject button
okay
yes but I mean one one as a thing as
opposed to the other case where you keep
flying
but something from the outside says
excuse me airplane your engine is on
fire or whatever
like one thing is you from inside the
airplane pull the eject handle and
you're ejecting
right and there's no you can't go back
the other case says you are simply sort
of
advising the world that this is
happening and then the world from the
outside is telling you no stop
you know do this thing is that is that
correct yes it's correct except that uh
we would prefer to not use the advisor
mechanism to abruptly change the control
flow we would prefer to use that as a
kind of information propagation so that
the in the intermediate layers through
which that propagates may decide that
for some reason they want to stop or
something
hold on I didn't understand that so hold
on look there are two cases one is okay
actually there's a there's another case
look
messages off by default are automatic
advice
pieces of advice being generated
which I don't think you're dealing with
here I mean I'm saying there might be
things in the code which I claim we
should sprinkle all over the place which
are messages off by default which you
can choose to put up a net and catch
them
if you want to
yeah but that's exactly what we are
suggesting as well was this event based
mechanism
which of it
uh well if you if we go back to how we
think of advice and how it's gonna work
uh currently we are basing that on a
certain event propagation model which is
very similar to what you're describing
no but no but look look in the internal
code we have a small number of messages
off by default like the packing messages
okay oh it's more than a small number of
messages off by default okay fine but
I'm saying what I have thought for a
long time is that we should have vastly
more messages that are off by default
now we may want to present them as
different things than messages but
although that is a pretty good mechanism
that we have right now there are all
kinds of things about you know
sort of little o that might not be the
right thing oh that's going to give a
symbolic result where in fact that's
probably meaningless but it might not be
meaningless
right and so then
the idea would be that you could have a
block of code and maybe this is
essentially what you have where you say
from outside the block of code you say
if any of the following weird things
happened inside this code I want to
generate a failure
am I making sense
yeah we would have this mechanism but I
think that we would still prefer to
discourage this kind of users why
because whenever you are trying to
decide about certain things of which are
happening inside code from the outside
this is very hard to make robust and
predictable
yes
yes but
look no I mean that's a no
yeah
I I don't think can I can ask a question
like there is there is one specific use
case for example right that you can use
these advice mechanics that I'm thinking
so let's say that I'm trying to deliver
pizza
um and and the function is very simple
there is one Gallery is producing pizza
and and it adds up to a guy is taking
the bits right now let's say that you're
gonna an endler that is putting I don't
know like pepperoni and pizza
and and what's going to happen like so
can you do that can you can you alter
the payload of the function another
question can you have like another layer
that is doing I don't know like QA
where you know you take the beats and
you inspect and you say this doesn't
meet the standards so you you throw an
exception
can you do this kind of stuff well I
mean that's basically as the message
passes upward
can it be monkeyed with
which is what confirm and close
is a you know you're going to Monkey
because it does not propagate it it
actively requires you to sort of repeat
it so to speak is that a fair statement
whereas here you're saying this will
float upwards by default
and not be stopped until it hits a
Handler
and so Ricardo is raising the question
could you as it floats upwards could you
start decorating it
which I think is a different issue but a
perfectly good issue that there's a
thing which is not the Handler is a sink
it's going to stop it right there and do
something with it
you know Ricardo is proposing that
there'd be some decorator mechanism that
can do things to it as it floats upwards
oh by the way if you had this message
take a look at it and then propagate it
upwards I mean you might you might do
that by handling it and then recreating
the message to propagate upwards
right yeah because what is this allows
to do like all kinds of stuff so for
example the the the in in Jungle you
know jungle the the the the web
framework so they they uh that they send
out messages every time you log in or
log out that allows you to you know for
example send an email to the guy that
says oh someone logged in uh in your
name because there was this again events
and now like can you can you also like
change user information can you do this
kind of stuff as when when the Evans
propagate before it actually reached the
you know the end of the the Lifetime
right but the point is if you repeat it
if you actively repeat it if you hit a
Handler the Handler is a sink it absorbs
the message but the Handler as its
handling code could regenerate the
message
so the answer is yes but it isn't like
you float it floats by and you put a
party hat on it it's rather you stop and
you re you know remake the pizza
putting a party hat on it when you
remake it right although if we do any
sort of you know automatic data Edition
like the stack right that'll be wrong
because
it'll be the stack at the point of where
the handler was rather than the stack of
when the thing was originally issued
okay
exactly equivalent too right you're
arguing for the need for a decorator
function
possibly that okay but that's a good use
Case by the way this is why we called
this listener and not Handler because
you know conceptually a Handler is like
a thing that it's handled it it's over
you know it's done whereas a listener is
a bit more passive something that you
know it receives it but it's not going
to modify it or do anything with it
necessarily but does it keep on floating
upwards so yeah if you register if you
register multiple listeners they all run
it's not like the first one gets to
decide whether to continue it's only a
Handler that stops IT
yeah but a Handler right now the advice
thing wasn't these are not interoperable
I mean you're either generating a raise
or you're generating an advisory
why aren't they interoperable
where we imagine that there could be a
sin I mean somewhere I had an example
um let me just see real quick that
Handler would have a syntax to well let
me just write it because it'll be easier
that you could have
um
something like handle expert and again
pseudo syntax but something that just
says this tag is an advice tag
um not an error tag or maybe I mean
perhaps you would even just say just Foo
but I'm not so sure about that so listen
listen the way to think about this I
think is this
there are absorbing handlers
and they're a non-absorbing handlers
like a listener is a non-absorbing
Handler
and
a Handler
okay the the the the point is this
a listener
okay if you write out yeah right why
isn't just a chain of composition I mean
what is just a pipeline like you know a
compositional function uh if your
registered identity is not doing it I'll
tell you why I'll tell you why it's
rather simple okay so let's look at the
function you know handle handle of
expert okay
and then it specifies how it handles
things
right
handle returns some piece of its second
argument as the result whereas listener
returns its first argument as the result
right in absorbing you're returning part
of the handling operation so to speak
right listener is a non-absorbing
function and so the difference is does
it return the first argument or does it
return you know in other words it runs
the second argument both of them run the
second argument the question is does it
return the first argument which can then
keep floating upwards or does it return
the result of the second argument
you see what I'm saying
just because are you suggesting I mean
we might have hypothetically something
like and register I mean this really
shouldn't be stateful it should be
something like with listener or
something it's not the right thing right
but but so what what you want is
something that says
listen yeah that's fine I mean we've
already got so basically okay
just okay what you've got is listen
and then then the second argument there
is let's
say you know action
or event arrow action just write event
arrow action or event error action fun
or something
okay all right so now right handle of
expert event arrow action fund
okay so the point I'm making is the only
difference between these functions is
the return value if you write Arrow you
know after the listen thing just write
an arrow to indicate its return value
the return value is just expert here
it's always just expire
right whereas in the handle the return
value is action Funk of blah blah blah
yes and this necessarily means that in
this formulation listeners who should
always be side effects of sorts
that's correct
a listener is a pure side effect here is
not not an absorber exactly
not necessarily have to
wrap itself around what's happening or
could it be in a core routine in a
separate thread
how that's a different issue I mean a
co-routine version of that is a separate
issue
but I agree that that's an interesting
case but but right now in our sort of
functional structure design that that
would be to me the difference between
those two cases it's perfectly
reasonable this difference
um okay so now
the question is the management of the
events
given that we understand what roughly
what handle and listen which aren't the
right names should be doing uh you know
now you've got the question of event
type management
and you've got this question of the
naive thing to do what are you doing
okay the the um
um
okay the naive thing to do
I don't understand why you have to
register the events I don't understand
that
what what why do you need to register
the events
why isn't it just that
okay okay and and the thing that
generates something for both of these
okay so then you've got then you've got
the ejector
and the
whatever it is you've got the that's the
and the outside that's absorbent and
non-absorbing then the two cases on the
inside are you know eject
and um
uh and advise basically
does that make sense
but inside do you mean like in the code
yeah in the code in the code inside
expert you've got two cases which we can
call you know so this is not types of
handlers this is types of
um
could be emit
no we've already got a function for the
map but it doesn't matter I mean the the
wait do we yes oh emit sound yeah
in a level okay the inner level is
both forget don't worry about the names
let's call it eject for now
propagate
no I mean don't worry about the names
okay we we understand eject raise
whatever it's ejecting from that piece
of code okay so case number one is eject
case number two is advise
okay so both of them
well they they take basically I don't
like this
they well they take a tag and some
payload material right both of them take
a tag and payload material
right
and
advise has a return value
you know this is a mistake it's the same
mistake as print versus Echo okay
advise
wants to be some kind of sub-value thing
I think because advice as you have it
right there is something that what's its
return value because it's still in the
code you see what I'm saying
yeah
I mean I guess we have been imagining it
implicitly as as null
um but I don't think that's right that's
the print versus Echo mistake
that Echoes the vastly more useful
function than print
you see what I'm saying
because Echo you can just insert in code
whereas the you know print you have to
put semicolon some things
yeah so I I claim
this thing I I don't know its name but I
claim it should be it should have a
sub-value thing
that it should basically the form of the
code should be advisory of tag comma
payload of expert
just like just like Echo
and you can even put an echo around it
if you wanted to
am I making sense
and then I understand what you want me
to transcribe I guess I don't understand
the behavior yet okay here's the point
the point is you want that advisory
thing to return expert right advisory is
a side effect only
just put an arrow Expo okay that thing
needs to return expert just as echo of
expert returns expert
with a side effect
concretely though I mean I'm just trying
to understand
yeah
well I'm saying you've got a big piece
of code you're evaluating it
and this is saying
well you're saying
you're saying how do I know whether I
should generate an advisory thing
yeah there's usually an if somewhere I
mean it's probably similar to I mean
currently it would be message right now
message also doesn't return anything
useful because its argument is not
something you need to return you never
look at it again so
I understand that point is sometimes
cumbersome to use but advisory
like message there's usually nothing
sensible to to return
okay but but let's imagine that internal
code because you know we need sort of a
a uh the internal code is generating
messages that off by default as
advisories look I admit that my my
sub-value thing is not convincing I I
don't fully I agree with you that
because of the different generation the
different way that you introduce I still
think there's something to be thought
about there about how do you you've got
a piece of code you want to insert
advisories into the code how do you do
it
well I think I mean
you know I pulled out this example
earlier because I just wanted to
illustrate um a different thing with uh
where'd it go about where I was I talked
about like why having kind of implicit
errors where you don't have to specify a
tag you're useful because this is this
is the implementation of the modern
package format prototype not gonna worry
about that but it's illustrative code
where I'm using a similar mechanism I
have this function and I just want to
write in the thing that went wrong you
know I don't want to be defining some
complex hierarchy of stuff yeah I agree
I agree that's hopeless hopeless right
not gonna work
right I think this is a similar
structure to what I would do if I if I
had an advice like mechanism it'd be the
same thing I've got like there's some
condition I'm checking for if
something's you know not what I expect
and then I'm just going to admit
something as a side effect and then my
code is just going to continue There
isn't really a canonical expression that
that advice might be associated with
it's not really something I want to wrap
around something it's just like okay but
something happened
why not I mean in the case okay I admit
that this advisory thing my sub value
advisory thing is more like a logging
function
but it's a logging function where you
can take action on the outside on
something that is being logged including
just log it
because I think we've been interested in
having a login function I mean just
write down logging of of you know
logging logging with double g
right
that's a useful thing in its own right I
mean that's similar to Echo
and so the question is is can we unify
the idea of advisories and the idea of
logging
if you look at the left hand side here
we use this logging example as
motivating example here you log in I'm
saying logging logging but I'm saying
this is we're using them at this
mechanism to print a log message but you
could imagine a shorter form of this
right where right where the logging of
tag right where there's a separate thing
look here's what I'm suggesting
let's say that the the overall concept
is a logging concept okay advisory
logging whatever they're also the same
idea
and that your choice of the outer
Handler
is
if you wanted to
you could either
okay so you've got this logging thing
that's being generated
you could absorb
um
sorry just a second
ah
um
let's see you could
um
the logging is being produced now you
can either absorb it somewhere by saying
I want to stop the control flow because
I saw that somewhere inside here I
produced a log message that said what
whatever it is
or
you could simply as it floats by you
could add something to some log
somewhere or some such other thing you
can have a side effect as it floats by
and you can keep it floating upwards
this mechanism most of the time you are
not going to use it directly like you
this is like an hook for other people to
use right I mean I'm if I understand
this correctly because you're saying
something like you know I'm emitting the
I'm doing the pizza example I'm emitting
the pizza right and from the outside now
I can I can decide whatever you know I
want to make an invoice which is a side
effect where I can decorate the pizza
which is a a change in the message
itself
yes those I think are the two operations
that you want to do but most of the time
you you are going to do it from the
outside and and this thing is actually
creating like a proper hook inside the
good uh look look listen there is the
fundamental thing here is there are a
variety of hooks that are being produced
and there's either
you know there are these messages off by
default
that
where they will do nothing unless there
is a Handler that
you know pulls them out of the ocean so
to speak and says I want to do something
with this
otherwise they'll just Float by
that's case one and case two is the case
which is a genuine exception where you
are ejecting from the control flow of
the code
am I am I right here
yes but there is also an intermediate
case imagine that somewhere in the
middle of the code some Handler that
receives this uh message so to speak
decides that something went terribly
wrong and then they decide to issue
exception from that point in the middle
that's fine but there's nothing
that's just a non-absorbing Handler
oh I see I see hold on hold on but but I
think this is fine learning because
let's say that that you have a piece of
code outside that is doing some sanity
Jacques cover over what you have
produced and I think this is a fine
operation to do let's say that you know
either like the pizza was too expensive
or whatever like you you want a business
logic that is look that is aborting like
but the whole point is the non-absorbing
function runs its side effect code that
side effect code could be a an eject yes
and there the reason why I mentioned
that is that I think uh the best logic
here is kind of binary like at normals
in normal circumstances we never allow
these
listeners to modify in any way the
control flow that would otherwise occur
with the only one exception that those
listeners might invoke eject and that's
the only way to change exactly that's
right
that's right or throw or anything else
or any other non-local you know Control
deviating Function
yes but okay my main point has been that
the otherwise message uh messages or
advices they are completely invisible
for the main control flow of the main
expression evaluation
yes okay so let's just roll back for a
second here okay so we've got these
we've got four functions here that we
know we have okay we've got and they
don't have the right names yet
okay they are the absorbing and
non-absorbing
handlers
and they are the
the
eject and advise
internal thing and I I really do think
we should try and combine the advise
thing with this logging thing although
perhaps they need slightly different
syntax
okay okay so to me this thing I mean the
names aren't right but to me this seems
to me to make sense
do other people agree with that and then
the the big other thing we need to
discuss is the management of tags
yeah
I do think I mean I think logging I
think we should consider it as a a use
case for the advice system right like we
should spell out like such an obvious
use case we should we should flesh out
what we think that would look like and
see if it can come up if we can come up
with a good design design that works for
logging that's a sign that the more
general advice framework right but I
think logging may be its own separate
function that has a sub-value character
like Echo just because that will be
convenient oh yeah yeah that's what I'm
saying so let's just talk about okay in
the logging case let's talk about
what
you know I think the typical thing
you're going to want to do is a with
logging function on the outside
that is similar to timing
yeah
so this I mean this is what I'm
imagining right
so we have like you said a with logging
like function that just for that scope
registers a listener and this would
probably log but registering your
listeners I mean it's just like with
logging just basically would pick up any
logging I mean okay this is the tag
management issue right with logging has
to either pick up every logging thing
from inside it or it has to pick up a
tagged subset of the things from inside
it
right and that could be an optional
argument to yes right but but now we
have the problem of tag management okay
so let's let's okay I think we've got a
concept here but the with logging thing
the basic point is no no just to be
clear that's not the right result that's
not the right result well the right
result and I'm just trying to write I
mean yeah okay yeah the right result is
something like
a like what we have with timing which is
a list of the actual answer together
with the timing data
see what I'm saying
right
so I mean I guess that makes sense the
only thing that I find weird about that
is that logging is something I think of
as something that happens like
continuously it's not really a returned
result
I I you know I I'm more think like I
mean okay
whatever it's a functional language so
we okay
but let me let me I just want to make
that point though because like logging
is often useful because if something
goes wrong part way through you look at
what the last log message is so it's
it's useful because
genuine side effect that's going to
somewhere else like you're logging to a
local object or something whereas what
I'm saying here is but I think this case
is also useful because I think what
you're doing here is you've got a bunch
of logging messages most of the time the
code is working fine sometimes something
goes wrong and you say okay it's it's
like a mechanism for switching on okay
here's what it is it's like you could
spray echoes in your code right but what
I do pretty often is I've got a piece of
code it works fine something goes wrong
I have to spray some Echoes into it
wouldn't it be nice if I could just
leave the things that say logging a blah
in my piece of code but they do nothing
unless I have an outer collect the logs
type thing right so I think I think that
they've given us three things on the
outside there's absorbing they do
something and it you know handles
something on the inside it's not
absorbing and then there's yeah
uh and still what you describe is
exactly the reap so mechanism
yes it is yes it is this is a special
case of leap so in a sense for these
logging things yes okay but but but okay
so all right so let's go back to tag
management okay
okay because the the next big thing is
okay so one base case of the tag tag
management
is you've got tags that are burnt into
the internal code because they are
basically messages off by default and I
I really think we need a bridge from the
messages mechanism to this so assume
that there are messages off by default
that can act as part of the collection
of possible things that are generating
uh advisories
okay
now you say well what other things we
want to basically have these giant
buckets
okay what Connor has said is when you
first write code
okay there are really two cases because
the eject thing is a little different
you know first when you write the code
you just want to eject you don't want to
say why you're rejecting you don't want
to you just want to eject for some
reason
and then later on
yeah I mean I hate this this is the
thing that we managed to do nicely with
with enclosed confirm is this lexical
scoping which means that you can use and
close confirm without ever thinking
about tags most of the time
but this is probably going to be
non-local enough you can't lose that
lexical mechanism right guys
yes yeah
right I mean I think just as a general
point about non-local stuff and I think
part of the idea here is just that the
problem with with adding tags is that
you know there's like a fair amount of
work you have to do on both the throwing
and the receiving end the idea here
might be that if you have a more
canonical set of tags you know there are
symbols and they're in this hierarchy
and that you register
you can do more you can just sort of do
a lot of that stuff one time when you
register the tag what about a more
extreme version of this what about if we
simply Define 15 kinds of of you know
tags
okay imagine that we can make an
ontology a taxonomy of errors and we
Define 15 of these things and the user
is like entities we've defined a few
hundred entity types of you know
glaciers and planets and who knows what
else you can make your own entity store
and add more of them
well actually it's a bad analogy well
yeah but I mean one of the main
advantages of the you know what we were
just talking about for tags is symbols
is that you can have them Scopes to a
particular package
but I mean I think there is room for
having some top level categories that
would be you know anybody can opt into
but you know so you don't have to
declare those things because yeah I mean
what I'm worried about is it's a serious
level of software engineering to start
declaring error types and so on
but but it's true that having like an
ontology of of Errors would allow us
internally to maintain some level of
consistency between you know all the
functions that we are developing
yes well let me just say I mean some of
these are probably controversial but
what I've got on the screen here is I
was just thinking of you know things
that might be useful right I mean this
is something where like you know okay
like the code got to a point that the
programmer hasn't implemented yet you
probably don't want that in finished
production code but that happens all the
time when you're fleshing out a project
um yeah I like this idea this this is I
mean this is cool it's like a CRM for
code in the sense that you know in a in
a CRM one of the big points is that
somebody has predefined you know the
stages of a sales process or something
like this
yeah and that's kind of using expert
knowledge to pre-define I I like this
idea so that people would routinely
learn oh I that's what I put in my code
when I haven't finished that part yeah
and also that's exactly how it works in
other languages which have been using
exceptions for a long time they have set
of predefined exceptions
yeah you can make your own but there are
others you'll often use
but this is a very different idea
because those exceptions are genuine you
know I don't know bus error or something
or whatever the heck it is but but you
see what I'm saying but they they're a
small number of of actual or they're not
I mean divide by zero things like this
they're very specific they're like our
messages aren't they no some of them are
pretty generic like IO error or like you
know some out of bound errors okay but
what I like about what Conor is
proposing here this is a sort of a
programmer management approach as
opposed to like
I mean
what you're describing are the runtime
you know the since the beginning of
computers type runtime type su's
whereas what Conor is doing is saying as
code is incrementally being built these
are things that can be there so in other
words what what
what what is saying is there's almost a
a an error that you put in that
represents
an error of undefined name you know a so
far in other words that's one of the
things where you go back and maybe we
have some coloring mechanism where you
can immediately see these are the places
where you haven't filled something in
you know unfilled error type or
something
I mean one thing is you could
conceptualize these as like there's
statements about what the programmer
thought was you know possible to occur
and there's different types of Errors
like you know an error that represents
invalid data from the user right where
the programmer could maybe anticipate
the user might give them something
invalid but they can't possibly
anticipate all the different ways it can
be invalid
um and so it's much more no I like this
idea it's a good idea I mean but these
this is a this is an ontology of of
programmer errors basically or
programmer
programmer anticip as opposed to an
ontology of things that go wrong in the
innards of our system
like divide by zero and so on
well he also has those right above right
he has file error and not sure what the
difference is between i o error and file
error
um I'm imagining it would have like it
would it would be it's validator would
ensure that it has a path to the file
where something went wrong I I need to
disappear in a second here this is um
but those stand error types away anemic
relative to what they should be if you
go through and look at the error
documentation there are it's a good I
think that'll be a good exercise for
people to do is go through and look at
that and try and see whether you can
come up with reasonable buckets for that
I think those aren't really the close to
the right buckets
they're things like
well I I don't know I mean they're
things and and some particular messages
might be in two categories
see what I'm saying yeah well that's why
I mean the mechanism the tag mechanism
lets us do that right if there's a if
there's a location in the code where an
error is issued that is you know a file
like error and a something else like
error
it would be tagged as both yeah I
understand I understand and the Handler
should just use pattern matching syntax
at least of a vertical Bar B type thing
to catch multiple things
yeah I view
all right I should run this is very
useful this is really good progress I
think
um and I feel actually you know I I
think the next step is for for you guys
to look I mean obviously a bunch of
naming things that are just total
disasters here and that would be
um but I think a very good Next Step
will be to actually look at the current
messages that we have and try and make
them into
bucketed errors and I really like your
idea of defining these um
uh
you know
um
an ontology of of uh sort of programmer
issues so to speak
yeah well do you want I mean
so
I you know our general thinking at least
my general thinking I can't speak for
everyone was that
we'd be well served to try to think like
in the modern world what do we think the
useful categories are maybe taking
inspiration from messages that already
exist but not necessarily
purely trying to sort messages that
already exist you know figuring out what
we think the useful buckets are and then
going back and you know trying to slot
messages into those buckets rather than
trying to like start by grouping
existing messages I would just I think
it's inspirational to look at the
existing messages yeah that that I agree
with we should look at them together so
I'm not claiming that it has to be uh
okay you're not suggesting we just flesh
out message groups
essentially you want yeah
I mean that would be like the really low
level thing to do which I think is not
quite right to just come up with more
message groups
oh the the message groups right now are
really lame
um
is one of the few languages they got a a
very nice set of built-in exceptions so
that that is something we should take a
look at as well
okay well but look
we didn't know okay the only thing that
we thought we were doing with the
current message groups was the off
mechanism often on mechanisms and so on
okay it was a different purpose that
those groups were developed for
now we have a much more programmer
programming oriented reason to do them
plus as I keep on emphasizing messages
that are off by default are really
important and we should put a lot more
in
and if that mechanism is you know maybe
we need to because really the only
difference between the mechanism you're
proposing and existing messages is the
mechanism you're proposing has an
association rather than positional
arguments
yeah I think that's I mean right
okay let's get another one of these
meetings soon and continue but we can't
do that right this second
um
okay
I think what we should plan to do is we
could collect some data on you know I
mean Ricardo mentioned how python does
things we'll get our own list of
messages do some initial sorting work
but I think
it might be helpful to just have a
meeting that's about let's try to figure
out a hierarchy for these we can do some
preliminary work that would be great
yeah but I think and if you can clean up
the things we've discussed in terms of
design and try and come up with possibly
some naming
for all of these you know kinds of
objects and I do think that because
logging is going to be one of these
functions I mean I think
yeah we don't it doesn't want to all be
all about failure
you know I just think it's
it doesn't necessarily want to have that
level of sort of
I don't know judgment or something maybe
I'm not sure I really have to go I'm
sorry this was not scheduled for so long
um uh
I I would like to continue this but I
really can't right now
um okay well thanks for the time yep yep
thank you good work this is great this
is progressing